[Music]
and up next is nick in hartford
connecticut hi nick welcome to the
ramsey show
all right thank you nicole sure what's
up
so i'm starting a new job next week for
making forty thousand but i have a
hundred thousand in debt almost all the
student loans about five thousand was on
credit cards um i just started watching
your uh videos on youtube and realizing
wow i've made you know
really dumb mistakes
um and so i know i need to go through
the baby steps to take all that what i
was going to do was restructure my debt
to more favorable favorable terms but i
wanted to see what your opinion was on
that to make sure i'm not making another
you know big mistake
restructure your student loans
yeah so my student loans about 67 000 of
them are private with a high interest
rate
um
and i've gotten a quote on how i can get
you know refinance that into one at a
much lower rate
do it
yeah lower rates not bad as unless
there's a prepayment penalty make sure
there's no prepayment penalty and then
get about the business of cleaning these
things up
once you get settled into this new job i
want you to pick up a second job
and uh make another 40k
and throw it all at this dad i want you
to be debt-free in two years
okay i mean really get after it man i
mean nick i want you to go cray-cray man
i want you to go nuts where your friends
think you need counseling because all
you do is work and pay debt
okay
i mean
wouldn't it be cool to be done with this
in two years
definitely yeah that's 40 45 000 a year
gets you there
and so that means you got to make 40 you
got to live on less than the 40 that
you're making now you need to go make
another 40 on top of this as your extra
part-time job and you'll be done in two
years
but all you're gonna do all you're gonna
do for two years is work
but you're gonna clean up this whole
mess in two years and you won't even be
what 25 years old will you
i'm 26 now okay well then you'll be 28
years old and you're completely free
or you can be 38 years old and still
screwing around with this stuff like
most people
okay that's really your two options you
got to get with it or not
and what ken and i were just talking
about there's lots of opportunities out
there i mean again you can pick up 40
hours
of extra job at walmart at 15 an hour
that's 30 000 a year
which means i know you can do better
than that even
so that's just exactly what i was
talking about yeah and 80 hours a week i
don't wanna be a workaholic you're not
gonna be workaholic you're working for
two years with a goal a workaholic is
someone who is mentally imbalanced and
gets all of their
uh
you know gets all this
they're addicted to work mentally that's
not what we're suggesting working hard
is not workaholism working a lot is not
workaholism it's called getting out of a
dead gum mess
and you just get back you get with it i
mean he could do a lot of stuff oh tons
of stuff i mean again
the the look the minimum wage is out of
place right now that if if you don't
uh find something it's because you're
not looking that's the reality if you
want to find something to get out of
debt it's there big time you show up
with a smile
and and some character you're going to
get 15 an hour or more and you can get
out of debt quick i'm telling you if the
demand is so hot right now it's
unbelievable yeah
if you don't then you're going to just
wake up 10 years from now and here's the
thing
two years from today the market won't be
like this it will not the job market
comes and goes like all parts of the
economy
it has swings to